Good morning thank you for being
here for our a joint committee
hearing of assembly select
committee on domestic violence
and committee on privacy and
consumer protection.
It's an informational hearing --
On the intersection of domestic
violence and technology which
was a shocker to me.
When not a few months ago we
found out that?
Well I I guess we don't think
that way by project perpetrators
do and I'm technology is being
used.
By to further --
Violate --
Of victims of domestic violence
and stole my team and I along
with assembly member child
decided that this is an
important issue that we needed
to address.
And I want to think --
The city of to argue for hosting
us I I have I represent the city
of guardian they have been just
amazing every time I call.
We call for anything they're
available something he jumps on
of here also I would like to
think of family member --
I tell for being here were
neighbors we sure on money and I
know this is a little bit out of
his district five I appreciate
the fact that he's here he is
the chair of of the our privacy
and consumer protection --
Committee and so I think came
and if you would like to see an
opening remarks sure thank you
very much out assembly member
Rubio.
I'm truly honored to be a part
of today's discussion --
Let me start off by thinking
also the city of Biloxi for
hosting today's the hearing.
As well as the California
partnership the and the mystic
violence the assembly select
committee on domestic violence
and it's chair --
Chair Rubio for your leadership --
And all of the our committee
staff of for their hard work in
putting this event together.
All domestic violence is a
problem that affects millions of
people regardless of race gender
ethnic groups socio economic
status sexual orientation or
each.
As the chair of the assembly
committee on privacy and
consumer protection.
I'm acutely aware that over the
past decade or so we have seen
an increase in technology being
misused. For to harass and harm
individuals.
In the privacy committee we deal
constantly with issues
surrounding emerging
technologies.
And the opportunities and
challenges the section between
technology and domestic violence
is no exception.
Technology has an incredible
power to simplify and improve
our lives in so many different
ways. For example technology can
help is better monitor our
children's activities. To help
keep them safe.
Knowledge you can also help is a
pain higher education or health
care online.
Knowledge you can even improve
our user experience so very
other traditional technologies
like phones television.
All cars even our air
conditioners and toasters.
But the advent of social media
and smart technologies such as
GPS and internet.
Connected devices has actually
created new avenues for intimate
partner harassment and violence.
In the legislature because
technologies always evolving we
are constantly working with
advocates and survivors. To make
sure that our legal protections
keep up keep up with new
technologies and new types of
abuse.
And as a result of these efforts
we have successfully updated
many of our laws. To ensure that
survivors of domestic violence.
Are better protected. For
example we have ensure that
survivors can separate your
mobile accounts while still
maintaining their existing cell
phone numbers.
We have also expressly authorize.
Hacking into survivors online
accounts for the purposes of
harming intimidating threatening
what the fighting to survive --
We have also enacted laws that
require the courts to prohibit
even stream party from taking
any action to obtain the
location or the address of the
protective party.
Now despite all these efforts it
is clear that individuals who
inflict harm continues. To
misuse technology in the
harassment and abuse of others.
Gap between the protections we
intended.
And the on going misuse of
technology invested violence
cases raises certain questions
specifically.
Are California's domestic
violence prevention lost not
being applied as broadly as they
might be.
In order new laws needed to
express.
Expressly cover certain abusive
behaviors.
At the same time what are the
best practices being used by
organizations both public and
private. To ensure that the
privacy and security and of
individuals are adequately
protected.
And today I'm hopeful that will
get answers to some of those
questions.
Put another way this technology
offer tools that individuals law
enforcement and the courts can
be used to better protect
intimate partners and family
members from harassment and
abuse. To that end I like to
extend a sincere thank you
without all of the available
information I believe that the
legislature will continue to lag
behind the miss uses and abuses
of a technology.
That is why your expertise and
experiences are invaluable to us
as we grapple with how.
Emerging technologies inter act
with domestic violence and as we
try to ensure that California
has the strongest laws possible
to protect its residents.
Redwood is absolutely crucial to
the health and prosperity.
Of the residents of the state so
with that thank you again for
being here and like turn it back
over to my colleague assembly
member I would be able.
Thank you assemblymember
telephone I have heard the story
many times are we know that
domestic violence affects people --
Of all ages races --
Ethnicity gender gender identity
sexual orientation in income
levels --
There also many ways that
survivors experienced abuse and
domestic violence including the
use of technology and I've
shared with many of you.
Are the reason that I five to be
the chair of the subcommittee on
domestic violence with because
my sister Susan Rubio.
Is a survivor of domestic
violence we had a rally in the
city of our money yesterday and
we had some very compelling --
Testimonials and to be on the
other side.
Domestic abuse it's very
difficult.
I spoke about --
My sister's experiences and
experience and agregue frankly.
This is --
This is the second year of the
three year restraining order
that she has on her.
Abuser and to this day. To the
name is a councilman in the city
ballpark she's an elected
official and currently running --
For state office and there are
folks that are saying that she
lied about her domestic violence.
Say that again.
The word is that --
She lied about her time to buy
[inaudible]
Now.
I completely understand why
victims of domestic violence
don't comport.
If somebody.
With they such public.
Domestic violence --
Case we actually went to court
and shipped in a three year
restraining order so we have.
Evidence.
That the judge said that she was
a victim of domestic violence.
Still people are saying.
That she lied and so when that
happens.
I think about the support that I
am able to provide for my sister.
And still again to the state.
Folks are saying that she lives
and so it's difficult.
Because she has so much support
and I always think about the
folks that don't have the amount
of support that she does.
And the folks there are locked --
Can't do anything about what is
happening to them the
testimonial from last night was
from a mother she said she was
going to try to make it.
Was from a mother that just lost
her daughter five months ago to
suicide.
She committed suicide because
she couldn't handle.
The pressure and be the abuse
that she wasn't during she left
behind two little kids and
family members that deeply
deeply Dr. Five she felt lost
and so the testimonial last
night was so compelling --
All compelling but last night
was just also a demonstration of
where we have not gone far
enough to trying to to prevent.
Domestic violence.
And when we started exploring
the topic of cyber bullying --
Domestic by do you I apparently
there's and and it's difficult
for me because I don't think
that way by of the of users are
using Alexa.
And what I'm not a techie person
but the be Abbas on home.
Devices.
Against their on the victim.
By either blasting the music at
five o'clock in the morning
turning up the air or turned
down you know just really.
Make it uncomfortable for them
and somebody said yeah.
Back if you'll plug it they're
going to be.
Abuse it will come home I'm
probably beat them.
From playing in the device.
We still don't grasp I don't
think as a society if we have
been through it.
On how deep.
The control is from a domestic
violence abuser and so.
It was very appropriate that
today we're having this hearing
and I want again when the think
assembly member town and all of
the panelists for being here and
hopefully we can.
At least.
Start a conversation about what
is happening and what we can do
and I have committed. To to the
partnership --
Twentieth to buy men's I'm
working on legislation last --
The last two years I've had at
least five pieces of legislation --
To help victims of domestic
violence.
What's to provide emergency
housing. To domestic violence
victims that are fleeing their
situations.
Are under the cal works program
and we were successful in the
governor signed it and I
actually heard.
From a counselor --
And she sent me a text that said
that our bill is making a
difference for her clients so I
think the partnership for for
their support on this and all of
the domestic violence --
Organizations that have weighed
in on our legislation and then
this year's --
Big piece of legislation was to
take guns away from --
The perpetrators right now under
federal law if you have a
domestic violence misdemeanor
federal law.
You have a lifetime ban on
owning a gun.
In California it's only a ten
year ban.
Which out when I saw that I
thought to myself my god I got.
It California's leading the way
and in this particular is.
Will come into effect is that
any domestic violence
misdemeanor.
Anybody they have misdemeanor
domestic violence is no longer
able to own a gun they're banned
for life so those are the two
big pieces of legislation but I
know that there's little fix is
that we have been able to
accomplish.
Big or small a step that we take
towards.
Hoping domestic violence victims
or Iraqi Keating be the the
issues of domestic violence is a
step forward so I want to thank
the panelists again for being
here assembly member child.
And with that --
I would like to call up our
first panel we have --
The it the general introduction
and to the intersection of
technology technology into that
the buy --
One and if we can have --
The first tunnel join us we have.
Been St safety net technology
specialist --
Specialist national network to
end domestic violence.
We have --
Christine Smith public policy
coordinator California
partnership two and that's fine
and and the abi guy goes.
Legal advocate for human options.
Thank you.
It's a to that --
We address the intersection of
technology and abuse.
Providing training and technical
assistance to survivors victim
advocates state the mystic
violence and sexual assault
coalitions.
Law enforcement court
personality turning.
Government agency and technology
companies.
On behalf of safety that
founders in the south working or
director Eric Olson like to
thank you for the opportunity.
To appear before you today to
address the joint assembly
select these concerns.
Related to the intersection of
the massive amounts of
technology.
Our members from across the
nation including California
partnership and the mystic
violence United is here today.
And the local victim services
assistance programs that they
work on behalf of are extremely
concerned.
About the impact of technology
misused on victims of domestic
violence. To give a number to
the enormity of the problem in a
national survey conducted in
twenty fourteen of local victim
service programs. 97% of the
victim advocate surveyed
reported that abusers women's
using technology to stop
harassing control that that.
That was in.
Twenty fourteen it's speaks
highly of your state figure
carefully considering this
complex issue in contemplating
policy development to help
enhance protections and increase
victimization.
Today I want to open with the
story and I ask that you keep in
mind that well it's just one
story it offers a good --
At the toll technology misuse
has on the physical emotional
and economic well being of
countless survivors.
A few weeks ago and they can
reach out to our team and I took
the call.
Over the course of a few years
this person gone back to school
had gotten a degree while
working full time.
And working a full time job I
apparently.
She just been hired to a new
position --
At a small firm in her field and
start date was set for three
weeks out. Two weeks left she
got a call from the owners of
the company they run at a second
post higher search of her name
on Google.
Something standard in their
And I discovered numerous social
media posts with her name and
photograph and very rude
accusations --
So been made on a personal page
of someone she briefly dated.
She didn't know about the post
until the employer call.
Has a position she'd been hired
to fill was public facing.
They told her that.
That they had to put her hiring
on hold it might not be able to
bring her on if the posted not
going down.
She contacted the technology
companies and five opposed to be
taken down.
And unfortunately they were
carefully crafted in a way that
did not violate the terms of
service of the social networks.
But they were good enough for
the company to reconsider their
offer.
The technology companies
responded to her report saying.
We reached out to our contacts
at the companies.
And asked them to reconsider
nope an impact on her employment.
Came down but the abusive person
posted Morley content on other
sites. For over two weeks we
play this game of whack a mole
the abuser would post something
she would find it and report it
we reach out to the company
requesting that opposed to be
removed.
Explaining the harm they were
causing.
And unfortunately the abuse
tactics.
Used ended in the worst and the
company withdrew.
survivors experiences a second
use -- offer minimum we'll tell
right isn't really Senate
harassment and precedent for
I will say some in fact it is
story straight is not it is
now and has in fact because it
is a consequences really and I
was a little the Senate there's
so many reasons persons that
time the level of confidence
as the final Sir hello
this is example -- misused
technology in a number of a
easily share and and it is for
years courses they have played
this is also a special song
live stream for the status
modernist offices rely on
anything allergy where my
reaction automation tools
that is turning on lights
and radios and televisions
on -- mostly surprised
because they feel that they
are in for their lives hello
seventy five dollars people
just because doesn't seem
possible in some cases they
literacy asking because yeah
maybe yeah on the other side
of the spectrum we hear from
others to do it Houston on the
state's latest technologies
and a half from the US being
online or saying this again
is this like right now -- it
is usually -- hello this is
possibility should be here and
-- the solution center this
is a thousand writers have
already he said -- this is
a life free from harassment
pieces -- uses office
systematically stripped away
actually financial resources
and saying on smartphones email
social media access to the last
for heating service lifeline
technology is our last
the person who uses
yeah platform not solution
access to technology
will not be there
technology disabilities
these we used to have
just consider the
so should we consider --
technologies to someone else's
thirty five hours a week by
disconnecting the survivor
and cutting off access
technology companies do have
Her appointment I for it's just
[inaudible]
The writer [inaudible]
Where [inaudible]
Results.
Right right.
Are socially --
There's a your bill off on
someone else. Three five our
right.
Yeah right yeah --
Run and they're less likely.
We often hear used.
It's time that we also that.
We recognize that this is a very
complex issue.
Maybe there's one nation reason
I don't see anything about.
Only say he's. Three billion is.
I am interested in.
Yeah.
This is --
This is [inaudible]
Yeah [inaudible]
Shop [inaudible] Two folks.
Online and I want to point out
that you are correct.
Action is willing get awfully.
Easier for us [inaudible]
To to right [inaudible]
The last.
And are directing the
perpetrators spot so I want to
thank you for for that.
Berman Rubio tenants have been
Q. burger my testimony today.
My name is Christine met with
the California partnerships and
enough to balance.
The partnership is the state by
domestic violence coalition
representing over two hundred
organizations several which
you'll hear from today.
Organizations their plastic
found survivors their families
and communities all across
California and there are public
policy communications.
Building efforts we line
prevention and intervention
strategies.
And social change.
We believe the by Shane
expertise.
Advocates and policymakers can
and the massive violence.
The partnership is also a member
of the national network to end
domestic violence.
We work closely with them on a
range of issues including
confidentiality.
Privacy and the intersection of
domestic violence and technology.
When a direct service
organization reaches out to me
for assistance on this
intersection?
This eighteen eighteen is the
first resource I time.
To an earlier this year Corbin
presented a very and for me.
According to the California
women's health survey
approximately 40% of California
women experience physical
intimate partner once in their
lifetime.
An estimated five point. Seven
five point seven million
California women and men
experience intimate partner
violence each year.
In many cases a portion of this
abuse instability debt by
technology.
The example here throughout
today's hearing provided look at
this pervasive in a section.
Well technologies will in
facilitating appears it's
important to understand and
address.
We must also remember that at
the core are the issues of power
and control that are at the root
of all domestic violence.
Whether technology is used or
not.
A server from northern
California asked me to share her
story with the own. Six months
to a year.
Operating from a physically
abusive partner.
She was hanging out with her
friends and a male friend walked
in his face a mixture of panic
and pity.
And said have you seen Facebook.
Her her think any side he's
added again.
She frantically turn on her
laptop.
Open.
And saw the naked at the top
half of her body.
Based on all.
Day about her.
The wrong twenty words written
all of them.
The naked photos were
unflattering.
Nothing even flattering photos
would have been okay but it felt
like salt in the wound to see
the photos that were never okay
to be used in this manner.
She did not agree to the photos
they were taken without her
consent.
After shout when she's reaching
for a towel --
Perpetrator with Y. as he took
the photo.
And laughed again when she
protested the removed the post.
Embarrassed he didn't even begin
to describe it.
The posts were made from social
media accounts created in her
name the hydrant at her friends.
And other posts were made and
her perpetrators seem and
somewhere made with you don't
names.
When she started a new job a
single mom of a toddler at the
time?
Learning and living life in the
aftermath of physical abuse.
Email began being sent to her
new boss.
Security and other employees the
company with pictures comments
and warnings.
Not to trust the for she didn't
find out about this until after
almost a year after working
there.
When the security guard hardly
mentioned that?
Wishing means never and in
between us her perfect figure.
The teacher looked at all the
photos.
Posted.
And tax and informed her that
because she was married.
The photos with the property of
her perpetrator and for future
reference it would really be
better not to take photos
without her clothes on she was
far too ashamed to even begin to
explain but she did not confess
the photos.
She didn't have the self esteem
at the time to get not officer
for blaming her.
And looking at the photos to
determine that there was no
crime when he could have
determined not without an
additional person looking at
these photos.
Eventually the postdocs. To
learn about way she could feel
safe online.
She had information about
herself and never posted
publicly in. Eight years later
she has only started to make
some post public.
Several years after her
experience she thought that laws
were passed making this activity
criminal.
It was too late to her but she
hopes the others I hope by the
five thank you for hearing my
testimony say in a line need to
show the survivor story with the
the partnership is a resource
for domestic violence programs.
And also the California
legislature as we work together
to and enough to balance.
Thank you very much.
The the problem she stopped
posting.
Because and she found weights.
Keep proposed secrets again.
But being is that the victims
are are forced to be the ones to
ask so that they are not
victimized again.
Thank you for that I appreciate
it -- And
then also next --
We have a new be guided those
legal advocate for human options.
Walk thank you hi good morning
everybody I'm yeah the valuables
and leave it with him and
options Constantine.
Also support tell support
immigration --
But today I'm here to talk about
the economy and how I see with
my clients when they are
disclosing.
That there is some type of
technology if you.
So a few months ago I actually
had a nine and her name is going
to be Mario we're going to
change the name.
And Maria came to me because she
actually wanted to know about
divorce she had been married to
her husband for about fifteen to
twenty years.
And she finally decided that she
wanted it and the relationship
legally she had been separated
for a few months and they had
been living in separate homes
but she wanted to officially do
it legally.
So I've been legal advocate in
our intake we actually asked
several questions.
And always ask privacy questions
some clients actually don't know
they're being stock.
And and it's I think it's fair
to say I sometimes don't even
know how to use my iPhone and I
can look with technology so for
someone that's older that
probably can operate within all
the G. or maybe we are just
aren't tech savvy.
We don't think that someone is
capable of stopping us through
our phone --
So while I was doing the privacy
assessment.
She started saying that no he's
not stalking me --
But when she started talking
about the abuse she actually
started to talk about how.
He sometimes pop in locations
where she was.
And not rose a red flag told
what does that mean --
So she started saying that when
she was having dinner with a
friend.
Every now and then she was
seated pick truck parked in the
parking lot.
And he wouldn't get out from his
truck he would just stay there
and the first time he thought
well maybe this is coincidence
may.
Following her from our house to
the restaurant and he never did.
So when she met with me I
actually educated her about
hacking softwares I can be
installed on your phones and
they can be used to track you to
monitor your whereabouts.
During the American during her
relationship when they used to
live together he actually
monitored everything she did and
she had to report to him.
Where she was at what time she
was going to come back?
And when she got home she had to
call him from a land line so she
needs so he knew that she was
home -- So
we started talking we started
safety I mean and IT review
resources.
Actually gave review resources
from the national network to end
domestic violence.
And she became more.
He thought maybe I am in stock
do my phone and I started asking
her she have a GPS location on
at all times she said yes they
don't know how to turn it off I
thought your phone comes like
that.
So I educated her on how to turn
off your GPS location how to
adjust your settings but a
really encouraged her to speak
out how by the tech agencies.
On which I'm glad he did when he
did more research she actually
started researching on you.
To double the cost and video on
YouTube that actually teaches
hackers hot hot.
But it also teaches you how to
know if your phone attack.
On a she was able to do the
status and if perform with happy
at the end of message will pump
on your phone same.
If your phone was hacked what
with the hacker able to see.
Well the message came up and
shoot at that moment me that her
husband was able to read her
text messages.
Was able --
I immediately told your go to
agency where they do tax so they
can see what's offer it is to be
can remove it and how you can --
If you want to press charges
what type of evidence do you eat.
So she ended going back to
eighteen T. where he purchased
her phone and they were too they
were able to a sister.
They ended up helping her figure
out what type of South Korea was
they took it out of her phone --
Make up the evidence and I am
unsure if she ever did press
charges.
But he came back to me one last
session to close her file and
when she did she was very
grateful.
That instead of us telling her
stop using your device.
ID with the tools and education.
For her to actually reach out
for it to individuals that knew
how to work the technology world --
And guide her so that way she
can use the device and continue
with your daily routine.
But now she does it in a safe
manner and now she knows where
she can go if she ever needed
for the house.
Thank you so much for having
today.
Thank you I hope world taking
notes because I think --
You know the information that
we're receiving is again mind.
Boggling to me to know that
people go to those lengths --
I would not have the you know
where to begin thank you for the
you.
To reference by.
You know kids today are.
Are you too bye all the time --
But it doesn't occur to me that
all of this can you know B. and
be -- Picked
up. To Christine in your in your
scenario the did the victim
actually report the incident to
the authorities.
On or the court for that matter.
Follow it with a quick about it
to her but he told her that it
wasn't friends.
Because he was because the
perpetrator with her husband and
her husband taking the photos of
her.
I see I I know that we have a
penal code that actually
addresses that that that
particular situation is called
because Cannella movie --
Law in a co six forty seven but
but I'll be happy to look into a
little bit more --
Because of that relationship to
spousal relationship. To see we
need to fine tune the law as
well on is worth hacking
situation is concerned there's
in fact I did it I did a bill
all on packing --
Anti hacking also of AB.
One five I wonder if dot also
would address that particular
situation but all out also
investigate --
As to cordon situation --
And they were receptive and
generally what we'll do we get
requests from survivors who have
been flat things and they're not
taking taken down by the company.
That will will look through the
terms of service ourself fine
but if we can.
Point to eat.
Reach out for the company point
to some of the harness being
because and and escalate done --
And sometimes having a voice in
the next helps because we do
work with them on a regular
basis around the development of
technology.
So as they're releasing --
New products or software or
policies --
A lot of times the work that we
do with them is.
To take those or release analyze
them provide feedback on how
someone might issues that are
might be harmed by it --
So they they've been very
receptive the hope the hope is
that technology of as the design.
Of it within the design process
they'll be a proactive
prevention based --
Model --
Adopted for the future that
doesn't work.
You know we'll do legislation
others to do the needed but if
they're these companies are
willing you know on their own to
do. To get you know --
Accepted your input I think that
may be a good sign right good
conversation [inaudible]
Thank you.
Something. To our panel to a
frost she's from the theater of
riverside county sheriff's
department --
List he direct [inaudible]
Yes and researcher at the
university of South Irvine
.
Thank you very much [inaudible]
And welcome [inaudible]
Yeah -- New
technology turn.
Thank you to the chair persons
and committee for the committees
excuse me for having here today
actually didn't prepare a
written statement simply because
I like to react to what I hear
everybody's --
Saying in the room --
Initially let me --
Say that --
In terms of what Christine was
speaking about in regards that
revenge porn cases and it to me
like that occurred.
Probably before twenty thirteen
or twenty fourteen when that law
was passed --
As a please someone give you
background on myself real
quickly --
On the master investigator which
just means I get paid a little
bit more --
Been around longer time.
I've been a detective --
For probably about fifteen years
a police officer for nineteen
years.
Prior to that I was a reporter
and a newspaper journalist.
So I have somewhat of an
interesting take.
On training etcetera I believe
training is actually are
solution to a lot of what we're
talking about here today.
And I some things ninety quickly
that not only does domestic
violence affect the victims that
we are here talking about today.
But didn't mystic violence
suspects are often times the
people who are committing mass
homicide.
Targeted by once it's set or in
our community.
Strangulation cases and more so
we've combined knows because one
of the things that we see it
riverside county sheriff's.
Is that we have a lot of silo
effect going on we have
different agencies working on
different projects and different
programs and not everybody's
working together and talking
together --
We do have a lot of laws on the
books and I wrote down a few of
them -- Just
in case I forgot all the sub
sections --
But I would like to start with
simply saying that.
You know police officers want to
do the right thing.
The majority of us obviously we
can get into this because we
love the money --
We got into this because we want
to help people.
But we are we need to be Jack of
all trades.
And we have vehicle codes penal
codes health in institutions
goes well for an institution
code and so on and so on and
then we are master of what we
choose.
So a lot of people choose to get
be masters and drugs and gangs
and homicide in all that sexy
stuff.
And some of us choose to become
masters and domestic violence
and threats.
So when I go back to that kind
what we're talking about we have
to seventy three point six which
is a restraining order law --
We fail so often is law
enforcement go to recognize that
we're actually looking at six
forty six point nine subsection
a and B. are stalking laws. Two
instances of addressing
repeatedly following tracking it
cetera and a credible threat.
Because we have lost along the
way the concept of training our
officers what credible threat
really means.
In the olden days if you will
for twenty two PC which is our
criminal threats.
Credible threat.
Was identified as someone being
right in front of you with the
immediate ability to commit the
act at that moment [inaudible]
Now.
We train our criminal threat.
If we're talking on online are
we right there at that moment.
That I we're not.
So a lot of people I think maybe
have a misunderstanding about
our online bullying and
threatening its center believes
because a long time ago the
courts actually dress with Brett
actually it.
If a reasonable person would
feel threatened in that
circumstance.
Then it's a threat so its course
of conduct.
So we have stock month we have a
restraining order laws we have --
Five oh two which is our hacking
and computer data law for
getting into people's emails
etcetera.
Everything we've been talking
about today there's a law that
exist me to do something about
it which is great.
But there are definitely places
where we can improve --
We could use some stronger
sentences in or surfaced you
skews me stronger requirements
in our probation sentencing --
Once we have domestic on
subjects are sentenced and
access to their phones and right
now we have limited access to
their phones.
It's great to talk about how
much of the technology companies
help us but as a police officer
sometimes a little difficult for
me -- I love
apple I have tons of apple
products get me wrong and many
great your apple just in case
you're watching that is a can to
basically.
Allowing them to testify against
himself I can't however get them
to give me their fingerprint.
Do I need not open this phone.
Anybody who knows your phone off
when you have to put in.
Your password.
So I can't compelling about it
give me that I can maybe not
even get into the perpetrators
devices to see what's going on
to see what computer technology
debuts -- I
think when we talk about
training it's not just training
police officers.
It's train all of us together.
Like you said it's your not
that's accepted.
Okay I'm not super tech savvy
sorry apple I'm not.
Having --
But there are people who are so
we could definitely use more
technical assistance centers.
That could work with law
enforcement and work with our
victims we have those around the
country right now and I believe
that partnering with the family
justice centers.
Would be a fantastic to do that
we have been we just centers
throughout the United States
throughout the world frankly.
And be able to use that a
foundational area for all of the
things we're talking about here
I think is great because all the
advocacy programs can work with
them.
All law enforcement to work
within the district attorney's
offices etcetera etcetera --
So one of the things that I I I
see that we're talking a lot
about different wars remote
smart home devices.
However we can also use those to
protect our victims.
Using remote smart home devices
is actually wonderful thing.
Having access to that which
we've actually obtained access
to some of those voter victim of
crime application utilizing some
of those monies to help put in.
Smart home devices for alarm
systems Lazar victim to take a
peek at her house where his
house before they don't. To see
someones at my door.
We are bring technology that's
out there right now not and I'm
probably using a brand name I
apologize again not as six seven
that allows us to see.
Rings are durable and to
actually answer them.
As if we were inside the house.
But it really is about.
Everyone getting on the same
page all of this there it's
locked changes additions
etcetera --
We need federal. To be online
the state to be online with
local.
And for advocates and our police
officers to be working together.
Multi disciplinary teams I feel
are so often the solution to so
many of the issues that we are
facing.
And if we have the availability
to train our officers who want
to do a good job.
This is how you care of this
case.
They want to do it but just as
many people in here are tech
savvy I'm a huge believer grant.
Grants and grant programs to
develop --
Rooms like ago throughout our
state.
We are work on and off the
violence against women Zakaria
we started one of the first
threat management teams in the
state. For an entire county wide.
And we did that because of the
we don't do great.
Now if we wanted to go out and
train on technology and I
provide free training across the
United States simply because of
the B. W. grant.
I'm able to talk about now come
aside strangulation training
people and things they've never
heard before or talked about
before.
Especially not in the context of
those who commit mass homicide
are often actually Stranglers.
So if we never look at that
before encouraging people to
look at those cases and letting
our officers no hate alive
Stranglers also happen to kill
police officers.
Which gives them a lot of
interest in that as well.
Too so as we talk about all this
and I can go out and do all the
training.
Think of what our officers and
advocates and community agencies
could do if we grant money. To
develop training on technology.
And to develop assistance
centers great and work.
From a law enforcement
perspective --
It just took us awhile to figure
out how to work with it --
For anybody who doesn't know
what I'm talking about the
California electronic
communications privacy act
basically says that especially
as a law enforcement officer.
If I'm going to go look into
somebody's phone I have.
To look specifically into
certain sections and tell during
my thank you and tell during my
search weren't exactly what I
need to look into that section
before was basically I have this
phone.
I have the phone.
Now it's great for victims
because I'm gonna look at a
victim stone she can give me
just permission to look at this
part this part in this part.
So if you want to share with law
enforcement what's going on in
your situation you can provide
this information to to me.
And I won't look at stuff maybe
you don't want to see or maybe a
barrister concerned about.
His people should feel
comfortable.
Coming in law enforcement not a
free to come along for some --
But from a suspect perspective I
need to work just a little bit
harder in order to determine
where it can go in that phone.
And that's fine we can do that
but that's also part of that
train so we'd love to be able to
bring thank you can click.
Here and next we have.
Founder and executive director
of ongoing excellence
[inaudible]
Hello everyone.
I'm lives leave founder and
executive director of online SO
us online also last week as a
nonprofit organization and we
provide resources to individuals
and journalists.
Who have been targeted and
threatened online who are
dealing with online harassment?
And similar to detect the frost
I was hoping to start to treat
this as a conversation at the
beginning of the conversation
really built on the perspectives
and questions everyone has
brought to the table so far.
Before that I'm happy to give a
little bit of an introduction
about myself.
So -- When I
graduated from college from the
university of Pennsylvania with
honors I moved back to New York
City to start my first job in
finance?
And I was so excited.
I was green I was ready to take
on the world.
When I was actually small
threatens and extorted online?
Aspen escalated to my apartment
door being kicked in by my
stalker --
Consider contacting law
enforcement and ultimately
didn't I considered getting a
restraining order but I couldn't
because I didn't know initially
who it was [inaudible]
And you know I've.
Shared my I probably share my
story every day through my work
but one thing I don't share
actually often and never in a
public setting is.
That I did find out who.
Was behind the harassment --
Through an I. P. address match
this is almost a decade ago --
And so I was on ask Jeeves dot
com one had existed --
To figure out how to get to the
bottom of what was going on and
it was my ex partner.
And the reason my ex boyfriend
and the reason I go and that
that will impact how on how my
credibility is viewed --
But in addition to the stocking
and extortion there were threats
to distribute my intimate images
to my employer --
And my parents [inaudible]
And as a high functioning
independent fairly credible
person.
I still.
Hi this challenges documenting
what was going on and what I
later learned in doing this work
on online harassment is.
Well their neurological changes
that happen in when you're in a
state of emotional distress.
And so what I want and how that
has led me to this work I do
this work I quit my job at
Morgan Stanley three years ago
to start online SO us.
Because I saw the in the new
cycle.
Individuals coming forth about
what was happening to them right
sometimes this issue feel so
expansive it's hard to get our
arms around what's really going
on you know the cross section
between domestic violence media
disinformation impersonation all
of the staff.
To it is very clear that only
her Austin's a massive problems
[inaudible]
And people are committing
suicide as a reaction to online
harassment [inaudible]
And I couldn't.
I could I have to stop playing
small behind my cubicle and
start sharing not only the human
story but what could be done.
And so when we start online SLS
that we first provided free
direct service including mental
health services from a
professional --
To anybody dealing with online
her.
We've since of all all to
providing information tactless
resources on what people can do
when they need help --
And building on the third to
frustrate you were sharing about
training.
And law enforcement one to do
the right thing but it's
sometimes unclear.
We talk even today about
multiple tactics.
So one of the things that I
wanted to offer today was.
The importance of the specifics.
About the audience the
constituents the issue that
they're dealing with which
sometimes it's multiple tactics.
But really --
Be specific about what kind what
someone access to us moving
forward.
Figuring out if we are funding
online harassment or developing
grants around that exactly what
type of toxics will it go.
To because we're at a point
where the narrative platforms
aren't doing enough law
enforcement isn't doing enough
that is not actually productive.
Because and hoping.
People in crisis we realize they
won't report done because that
narrative has been so pervasive.
And if they won't report them we
want to really understand what
they're dealing with what's
going on and so.
I wanna be mindful of time and I
have many things to say.
But I think that really is my
own take.
Away from this discussion.
And building on what was said so
far really.
At the intersection of task.
Media politics.
Law enforcement law.
Now more than ever it's critical
we come together.
All the efforts and coalition
building and being specific and
getting understanding specific
use cases.
And then working towards change.
I believe is the pathway.
So thank you so much for your
time and look forward to
continuing this discussion
further.
Just one comment --
Those about what you're saying
about the harassment online --
I we are public officials and
we've had several incident --
Instances lately where we're
being harassed but it's very
easy to hide behind the keyboard
nobody can --
You know really hold you
accountable for for those.
Are is the perception of that
nobody's gonna hold Burke
countable for for you doing the
cyber stalking.
Are in my case again a public
official so that's really the
laws are very different --
By my fast at the look at the
comments the look at the
comments.
Because they were very very rude
rude and I mean to the point
where --
They would they literally had to
like not let me look at the
company --
By I have --
The the ability to call upon you
know we have --
The CHP that takes care of the
assembly members we have a tech
that we call them sergeants and
at the capital that we can call
and they're doing a security
assessment of our offices.
So we have access to that and
for folks that don't have access
I want to thank you for for
providing that access --
Because like I said we are have
the access button most people
don't and it's very easy. For
the perpetrator to just hide
behind their first amendment
rights really isn't there
talking [inaudible]
Taking the I will.
Being attacked or savings that
aren't kind to others needs to
also be address because I think
we've developed this culture
that it's like a wall.
You know if I'm online so it's
okay and it really is and so
again thank you --
For conversation today and then
so now we have a cat low
researcher at UC Irvine thank
you and welcome.
Yeah -- Yeah
underserved track university
help Irvine and my background is
both a technical issue logical --
Intriguing and I work as a
consultant interested safety
which is typically you know
issues relating to harassment --
And so I've been able to sort of
work and see these issues from
inside the companies as well as
doing.
Crisis support facilitation for
a target to the views and
harassment.
Of which came out of me running
on link use for women who found
themselves being targets and
have the resources at all --
And so after aggregating enough
resources we realized --
Well I guess we should if is a
resource we should start you
know Sir deliberately helping
people --
And so.
After doing that work for a
while the prices were great I
realized that I wanted to see
the inside of companies and why
these decisions are being made.
About how these platforms for
for being designed just from the
stock or from.
Across platforms and they you
know reported it on every
platform and none of them got
you know they don't know who the
actions.
And in what I realized is --
As she started crying at some
point I was I was going through
this with her and like --
No I am so sorry this is really
difficult I understand you would
know I'm crying out of happiness
because I thought it was going
crazy.
Because the way that these
platforms would consistently
denied these reports --
Was sort of a form of like what
people say plating is you know
sort of imposing a different
reality on on of the experiences
of of this type of harassment --
And so.
This isn't actually a single
story this is a several dozen
stories you know over the that
have happened over and over over
the past.
Year and a half.
Year and a half alone is --
When I with somebody who
[inaudible]
And please [inaudible]
She had we actually documented
like here shoes very savvy
engineer to do to document
everything but when she went to
the police station they had no
idea what to do with it and they
just turned her away --
And she had no idea what to do
at that she had no means like
shouldn't know try to go to a
lawyer.
A and there's no guidance there --
And so.
You know and they basically said
like you know just up online
which is sort of a common
refrain.
That doesn't actually work given
that.
You know it's a very important
for both here professional and
social life to do that --
And in many cases to be
connected to your support when
you have a an abuser.
A and and this is becoming a
worse problem there's a two
thousand seventeen survey by a
cue.
That documented in increase in
people who have and severely
harassed online which includes
like sexual harassment.
Stalking and doctor thing and
they demonstrated that where
there's a particular rise --
Or a particularly high point for
a younger generation people
between eighteen and twenty five
so it's it's been getting worse
it of younger people as well.
Specially.
And and so speaking from the
side of working within companies --
There actually are many
challenges and many many of the
people who work on the trust and
safety team that time companies
are.
Very good and very well
intentioned people who do have a
lot of education --
But there are a lot of attention
with privacy for example the
challenges you know how do we
increase.
Does the gathering information
that can be useful for a healthy
these cases without creasing
surveillance that can be used by --
State actors known bad faith --
Internationally or locally.
You know being abused by hackers
and other kinds of compromises
and and the security of data.
And so.
You know a lot of teams are kind
of stock in there also under
resource.
And so one of the things that I
see is that that I think there
can be some changes in in the
tech industry is that there
right now there's very limited
escalation infrastructure.
In the sense that if you have a
severe case you know it it's
very difficult to get escalate.
The systems by these companies
are designed to be one size fits
all so you know in there
moderation their huge scalable
commercial content moderation
systems.
They basically a limited amount
contact they feel like you know
the text of the thing that was
reported.
And in isolation a lot of the
time it doesn't look that bad --
But in aggregate and of being
far far worse and so there's
very little interest.
And I think that if there are
more resources --
Allocate to a more pressure
around this kind of escalation
that these kind of prophecies.
Of for escalation I think that.
Would go a great way towards
addressing these issues with
severe abuse and harassment --
And so.
Right now --
There's some there are a few
partnership with the many
partnership serving former tech
companies --
That are you know NGOs non
profits --
And I've had to see that --
Advocacy organizations out but
right now there's limited
integration you know --
These organizations see very.
Little into the operations of
these tech companies.
And a very little agency to do
very much about that so I think
having more way behind the
amount of insight of and
participation they can happen
that process is very important --
There's some precedents for
dealing with this --
Plot have had to build system
for dealing with child
exploitation --
Materials alongside government
agents and some social media
platforms of invested more
training and resources.
For individuals and specialists
who actually dig into the
context.
Are so that they can sort of
identifies movies more severe
cases of abuse.
And so.
The recommendations that I would
I wanted to point out is one is
one is what not to do is.
A common response is removing
and identity right at you know
making it difficult to have an
anonymous user names and things
like that.
But it is not actually very
effective solution and actually
pulls back from the protections
that people have --
To avoid abuse so being
anonymous allows you to escape
your user and it's been a common
practice to have a fake name on
Facebook.
Stay connected to your support
network while avoiding your
views there however that
violates Facebook's policy.
And I get taken down and often
does when the of users find out --
About if if they find out about
that account.
So.
Really going back to what is
we need their infrastructure
prophecies.
Of both in the relationship
between law enforcement agencies
and these platforms --
These escalation form of
escalations along side --
Advocacy organizations --
And I think.
The end and actually --
Along to get technical experts
to and actually your point
before the technical experts in.
Of law enforcement agencies to
do that kind of education so
that people know what to do with
these social media --
Records --
And what with all the law and
with all that documentation.
And online platforms typically
rely on target to abuse to
actively advocate for themselves
and actively report --
But a lot numerous studies over
the past couple years have a
demonstrate about.
How targeted views choose not to
report after a period of time
because of lack of trust the
platform or fear of?
Retaliation --
And often don't understand how
best report and how that abuses
even being perpetrated in the
first place so having more
proactive means to identify and
reach out to targets even to
confirm if this is actually
happening to them --
It would be really important
because right out of many social
media policies.
Of require that people report
first.
Aye and and I think one of the
biggest threats to severe --
Serve targets of severe on
harassment of of severe online
harassment have been data
brokers.
As a data brokers are --
Well of the workers are websites
aggregate public and private
information where you get it
there like white pages dot com
and studio we can pay to get.
Somebody at yeah address family
members and everything and so
these these websites --
Third dozens and dozens of
popular ones that prop profit
off of compromising the privacy
of citizens.
And the that aggregating
information and in all of the
same location and making it
accessible does decrease the
effect of privacy.
Of a citizen and especially of a
target of abuse --
It works fine about it in my
experience is that is easy
information is often quickly
updated after you move after you
take your contact information.
So a lot of the measures that we
used to protect people don't
work because of these data
brokers --
You can remove a lot of
information but it cost you
between a hundred fifteen five
thousand dollars from services
and you don't know which ones
are active.
So and it it it is well known as
a mod reviews among --
Forms online and it's very easy
to find out about.
So what what I to the rock hall
of of for time it is important
focus on technical education for
long forces.
Law enforcement of prophecies
escalate harassment cases
resource allocation for trust
and safety measures --
And more integrated partnerships
with advocacy orders not just
having a partnership --
And I think and and again
working on well how do you
address data brokers had we
address that this is an easy way
to profit --
And is not a regulated in any
significant way --
And so I think it's important
not just a center best practices
and design prophecies and
education so that they can of
all along side how these
technologies are changing.
In the way that they knew
harassment and how her after
learning more sophisticated
techniques and strategies more
easily.
Thank you thank you.
For the we have --
Questions or comments I. S. C.
assembly member --
Tower --
Figures being over here I see a
couple bills coming.
Onto the privacy committee I can
I can feel it.
And I would be honored to
partner with you on some of
those so I'm putting it out
there are.
So think you if there's no other
questions I want to thank the
panel I appreciate --
You and we look forward to
working together so that we can
assist assembly member town was
built.
Thank you yes.
I just.
Wanted to add one thing in a
couple resources so the first is
another interesting place to
look could be evidence
preservation.
So the challenges of evidence
relation on the target --
And what kind of evidence.
Do we need to provide law
enforcement or to the platform.
And then there the first is --
Without my consent.
And nonprofit organization --
Focused on actually analyzing
California domestic violence
related law has a domestic
violence restraining order
digital.
Chichi.
And so.
I think it's a great place to
look and direct people direct
folks.
To and then there's been a
couple recent reports that you
may -- That
could be helpful to draw from.
So the United Nations special
rapporteur on violence against
women just published a report --
In June.
Around --
How online violence well as
amnesty and a group called a
troll busters with the
international women's media
foundation --
On how.
This affects female journalists.
Just wanna share by --
As places to draw from the
future thank you.
If you very much I appreciate
the conversation.
Thank you.
Next up we can we have personal
story and the use of technology
in the message violence I'd like
to welcome our third panel out --
Jasmine Montero's on people
department manager Lara's health
and Jack month NARAL home --
Social service manager at so he
re justice center.
Up [inaudible]
Yeah [inaudible]
Welcome.
Okay so high everyone many jobs
and Montrose and want to thank
the committee for having me here
today -- So
I am bill people to the manager
at Lawrence house.
So Lara's houses the nonprofit
agency that services victims of
intimate partner violence --
Wearable cafe you can process --
Ensuring that nobody is alone or
unprepared the day after hearing --
So this year we're going to
support nearly twelve hundred
victims --
Through this process many of
them have experience and to
report to us that they have been
experiencing some type of
technology abuse --
Added peace twelve hundred
victims would say roughly about
75% of them.
Have reported some type of kind
of you know technology abuse --
In different ranges so kind of
the reason for family going to a
personal story about a client
and kind of what we did to help
them with the technology issues
that they were experience.
But we do believe that victims
of intimate partner violence or
people in domestic violence
relationships are at higher risk --
Of the perpetrator gaining and
using this abuse against them
the reason for this is because
they're just not some stranger
who's trained target somebody at
random --
It's somebody that the trusted
at some point somebody who might
know their personal information
so this gives the perpetrator
access to their devices.
Access to knowing their personal
security questions to be able to
answer certain things for them --
And that puts their devices.
To use -- So
with that a compromised device
that the compromised accounts
can give the perpetrator access
to the locations are track the
tracking their their whereabouts.
So from that they're able to
sometimes reader text messages
listen in on conversations even
access their voice mails.
As well as sometimes even
remotely delete evidence from
their computers are the phones --
That they might be using for
this restraining order hearing
that we're going to be assisting
them with --
So with that I do want to talk
about one specific client that
comes to mind when we talk about
technology --
For the purpose of the story
let's go ahead and call --
Thirteen so dean came to us she
had already petitioned for a
restraining order.
And when she got what she had.
A stock of evidence --
And it was.
Screenshot --
In just personal information on
her social media accounts school
change.
She just didn't understand why
she would go back change this
password but the pass which just
capital change back with
accounts that.
Kept getting access into.
So with that we worked with her
on resetting the password to her
accounts but at the end of the
day did she didn't feel safe.
With the devices because she was
already doing this so we work
with her and do some research on
these accounts --
But at the same time.
While she was worried about her
social media and online account
she was also.
Going to her local grocery
stores she was going to a local
Starbucks and her perpetrator
would appear at these locations.
So there was. Too much going on
at once that she decided to kind
of take herself off line and but
the beast was still there yes
talking.
So access those are garage door
and she turns to her car and she
sees.
A typical little yellow brag
sticking out of the grill of the
car.
She went towards the car.
Took out that yellow right that
was there and wrapped inside
that yellow rod.
Was that I phone.
The iPhone was connected to her
car battery.
And came to the conclusion not
from this aye full he was using
the find my location.
Probably had a software on there
to be able to track where she
was and this was the reason why
he was showing up at every
location that she was not.
Whether it be the grocery store
at the local Starbucks --
So with that she didn't team
it's safe to the touch the phone
from a car right battery in that
moment still she waited a little
bit --
Eventually after doing some
safety parting with advocates --
We were able to go ahead and
remove that before one of her
hearing --
But at the end of the day.
It was the question how we need
the court was going to answer
the question how do you know.
That it's this person that
fooled the cities tortilla --
Luckily with hers that was a
really easy solution because the
very first thing perpetrators
email address on there.
So.
That was an easy case but at the
end of the yeah I think it comes
down to you know meeting with
the client so when we met with
her we assisted her in helping
our children passwords --
We also did research on her
account --
But everything still kept
getting changed back so.
After with last week partner
actually with a local
cybersecurity company and I feel
that back something that is very
beneficial.
To advocates and agencies work.
None of us had any.
Knowledge of what was going on
with tech because we're not tax
ID some of us might be some of
us might not be.
But we have a local
cybersecurity company actually
come and do some extensive
training with us and teaching us
what fishing was what.
Hacking is and we actually got a
full expense knowledge and we
created helpless to be able to
provide to our clients.
And showing them and actually
determining if their phone a
safer unsafe --
So with her specifically we
actually helped her --
Reese --
Completely your first and this
is work we did with her --
Because she had tried going to
police and they would be like
but how do you know it's this
person doing this when she would
children screenshots on
everything bloom Chiu --
But that we did the factory
resets with her and from there
we work in educating her on the
site where --
Applications that were out there
to try to maintain her devices
safe -- From
not once everything was done
eventually she did come back
online she alone here in
California all her family was
out of state and our
communication was to face the
with everybody else --
But without we also educated her
on how to keep her account see
from here on out --
And if we wouldn't of had this
chain personally I think it
would have been a little bit
harder for us to prepare for it
to continue on with her life and
feeling safe.
Our social media accounts on the
internet --
So we educated her on the two
factor authentication and on a
password reset feel not just
specifically what's your laptop
when somebody can go on to your
profile I just find your high
school in the know your mascot.
So we did this education portion
with her --
From there the client did end of
obtaining her restraining order
and eventually criminal case was
open but it wasn't in regards.
To the happy it was in regards
to everything else it was
because of the violations that
were happening in the
restraining order and him
showing up at these locations.
But from there --
Center they're telling me that
she's doing great nobody has
been going into her counsel she
actually feel safe on the
internet out --
But with that.
I think some tools.
That we often see with our
clients one of the most
challenges is going to be.
You know being able to tie this
evidence to vote of users --
For example I know one time I
was in court and there was
somebody that actually worked in
law enforcement trying to obtain
a restraining order and they
have all the resources they were
showing I. P. address as they
were showing.
How they knew it was the
perpetrator versus somebody that
comes to you know --
And a local agency we have
access to resources but it tends
to be limited at times so we try
to do as much as we can with --
Even try to find with us it's
great that we have this
partnership where we can
actually even communicate with
them and after moved on the full
assessment.
If it's still not safe will send
the device over to the city --
Cybersecurity company but a lot
of agencies and people that are
doing this on their own don't
have access to these things --
But I really think it comes down
to being.
Providing that education portion
to advocates to local law
enforcement.
To anybody possible to try.
To let them know how once to the
internet and to have to take all
these precautions.
Because at the end of the day.
Why should they have to do this
even though?
The abuses occurring --
But with that so.
I just wanted to say thank you
for having me as a before
allowing me to show my
experience with claims.
Thank you rate on next to her.
Job [inaudible]
Q. -- Thank
you for the opportunity to give
my statement and a little about
the intersections on domestic
violence that knowledge and
immigration --
And the new grand experience as
we start moving towards
solutions I think is important
to also.
Take into consideration that
different community access
technology differently.
My name is judgment I and I'm
the social services program
manager with the taxi just a
center.
In my row at the diary I oversee
the social services program as
well as support survivors with
case management counseling and
referrals.
I first are working with
immigrant survivors of domestic
violence in two thousand and
five and have since work in both
east and west the center is a
national nonprofit the uses
holistic approach providing
legal.
And social services
representation for immigrants
undocumented immigrants victims
off gender based violence.
We also do public education and
advocacy.
Our mission is to protect
courageous immigrant women and
girls who refused to be victims
of violence by elevating their
voices in your communities.
Courts and Congress. 71% of to
hurry clients have experienced
domestic violence.
Nearly half have also
experienced a very different
forms of abuse.
Immigrant women are tK times
more likely to experience
domestic violence and the
general public. 72% of abusive
partners fail to give there's
thousands of legal status any
use that as a tool of control.
One out of five better immigrant
women site immigration
consequences at the fear reason
for leaving the adhesive
relationship.
It is also important to
recognize the domestic violence
among immigrant and refugee
populations are not rooted in
the specific cultures.
But in part Cherokee and
oppression.
In addition they immigration
experience is often Rio in
violent.
Abuse extortion and the
different forms of trauma.
Post immigration stressors can
have impact in family dynamics
and create the conditions for a
domestic violence with a
immigrant and refugee population.
Leadership thank the Grayson
process --
Is impacted by many factors.
In kicking can call socialize
the isolation limited English a
language proficiency can limited
access to resources and when we
talk about --
Language access is important to
also that to talk about it is
not just about.
Foreign languages and English
technology itself is the
language I sometimes a struggle
with.
Some off the terms that we had
been using here so that's
something that we have. To take
into consideration as well when
doing --
Community outreach --
We also most of most observe how
institutions and systems off
technology are rooted in
privilege.
I first learned about the term
she's you know divide.
On a study conducted by the
center for justice Lawrence and
community at the university of
California Santa Cruz.
They thirty highlighted how
access and use of technology
tends to zero social economic
disparities.
And those disparities my further
reduce opportunities for
immigrants to adopt
technological skills.
Another thirty conducted by the
university of southern
California foundation grants
have a higher ownership of
mobile device.
The lower for computer and
internet access per household.
Latino immigrants also have the
lowest rate of computer
ownership for household --
When compared to white US born
Latinos and Asian immigrants?
80000370% of 40% of foreign born
Latinos on the computer.
Another thirty conducted in
200-020-0012.
By the welcome center the
welcome center for the new
Pennsylvania.
Found that when it comes to
immigrants personal use of
social media.
Texting has an overwhelming
prevalence 95% of the
respondents reported using their
mobile phones to send text
message.
If this number is significantly
higher than the percentage of US
adults --
Cellphone users that overall is
about 73%.
More than half 58% say that they
do so often and those who say
they never sent that.
Text messages were all --
Eight all forty or older forty
years old or older.
In that same parking demographic
to keep in mind when you are
working with folks from
different ages and backgrounds.
We also see clients where
children are the ones support
their parents with the
communications via text or
electronic devices.
This is something the provider
should consider when
communicating with clients doing
outreach or also thinking on
different like.
Ways to use evidence --
Or communicate with clients.
As expected many immigrants use
social media to communicate with
their support systems back home --
44% of the easy grams Condit
responded on their report.
Say they use mobile phones for
the show the nine one stop.
However the general knowledge of
self when you use seems to state
limited to those applications --
We work with clients that
although they use Facebook Daly
what's that daily when we have
to talk about different safety
deep so different.
Technological applications so
you get is that can help then
they need some additional
support in that area --
Is my limited to communication.
Are we still have a long way to
go when it comes.
To our community education on
technology and technology access
itself --
But he can be a pearl out
process --
We can do some safe work towards
safety improvement.
And also on evidence gathering
as well --
All the issues are you related
to how it use use technologies
as to of control and I don't get
into because I think many folks
here highlighted that as well --
We have also seen a lot of
social media is intimidation one
thing that I can hear you today.
Is -- The
LGBTQ community and their
partners and social media to
their families when they have
not done you know that's a very
brutal way to take.
Something from you --
Also -- We
must reveal legal procedures for
survivors to get electronic
properties on a track in a
timely manner.
Up for example I am myself a
survivor off domestic violence
when I first immigrated to do
not stays in.
Two thousand four I ended up
having to go to a better shelter
in the last name only with the
clothing on my back.
And in order for me to go back
and get my electronics I had to
go up life for a restraining
order wait thirty days in order
to have a judge. To then have a
shared go you'll get at least
all your properties.
And by the time the perpetrator
had already had access to the
computer on my password to reach
out to a family had.
Gotten to my email accounts so I
think you know the legislative
like I I really appreciate this
opportunity because will be good
to look into a way.
That survivors can get access to
their properties one uses the
one that state of the house or
that user has control over their
properties --
Yeah so I'm just honored that
the California party she to an
the mystic violence asked me to
be here.
And I hope to continue to
contribute to efforts to help
discuss wrote to the roots off.
Domestic violence in our
communities and creating my
protections just survivors.
Thank.
I also have the story.
Pop up when you are talking --
And you know with everything
that's going on with the federal
system and all of the
immigration --
Controversies --
There was a case where --
Eighty documented --
Husband had an undocumented --
Beat her and said if you know if
you do anything I'm going to go
to the party.
And eventually started --
Abusing the children as well and
saying.
What do you get a deal and so --
It is very difficult especially
with the situation that's going
on on federally by.
It's hard to point --
To some of these services
because I think a lot of our our
immigrant communities are free
of point of coming forward
because of the different things
that are going on and so.
I know that now more than ever
we need your support and
services to to be I'd.
Aye immigrant communities and no
believe it or not --
Even if they are documented the
perpetrators --
Somehow brain washed the victim
into thinking that they have
power over their immigration
status so even if they're
documented I've heard them say
well you only documented because
I allowed it so I did a moment I
can call and take it away.
And if you're not educated and
have no idea.
And being very basically a slave
to the perpetrator because
you're just trying to maintain
your your life and maintain your
family so thank you for being
here with us today --
And I want to think assembly
member child --
For participating this morning I
know we're all running around by --
Thank you again and if there's
no --
Questions will have an
opportunity to have other
questions when we finished by
thank you for your testimony.
The okay so next we have
empowering youth in using
technology and the mystic
violence --
I'd like to welcome our fourth
and final panel no the five
crisply bean --
Prevention and policy division
director at peace over violence --
We also have the posh I'd done
on prevention educator how a
roof.
And Devin mallet prevention
specialist at one eight Glendale
.
Okay so to the assembly members
Rubio and talent to this joint
hearing and to the partnership
for having us here today --
POV peace over violence is a
community based organization
that serves the greater Los
Angeles and Westinghouse area.
To help people build healthy
relations unity is free from
sexual domestic and
interpersonal violence --
I oversee our prevention
department at peace over
violence which includes a lot of
activities for youth education
and youth leadership development.
We provide violence prevention
education in the classrooms for
students --
We do leadership programs like
our students together organizing
peace program in schools our
summer youth over violence
institute an internship program
and we help provide spaces for
intergenerational conversations.
Between young people and adults
to talk about building healthy
relationships so I want to say
thank you again not just for
having the space to talk about
this really important
conversation.
But really ensuring that youth
and prevention are part of these
conversations.
On unfortunately teen dating
violence is something that
happens and it's not often
talked about as part of these
broader conversation about
domestic violence --
And it's often not taken
seriously in a lot of times just
kind of label teenage drama --
But we know that according to
the National Council on crime
and delinquency actually one in
three young people deal with
some kind of of violence from
their dating partners whether
that be sexual emotional verbal
physical.
Or digital --
And women and girls between the
ages of sixteen and twenty four
actually experience the highest
rates of intimate partner
violence which is three times
above the national average.
On and you know that I can have
lifelong effects on young people
are not only when it comes to
their mental health but then
sometimes becoming adult.
Victims of domestic violence
after.
Social media can two teen dating
violence occurring --
There's a correlation that when --
Some sort of cyber or digital
abuse is happening within a
relationship that there is also
physical and sexual violence
company so that could be an
indicator to kind of look.
And see and dig deeper as to
what's occurring in the
relationship --
We know that things like
Instagram and Snapchat and other
forms of social media can be
used to create an environment
that's threatening or
intimidating in order to control
that person's partner --
And that social media can feel
relentless it can be anonymous
you can feel inescapable and
like someone mentioned earlier
we've seen unfortunately people
and people across the country
die by suicide because of the
pressures put on by social media --
And it kind of makes sense the
appeal of social media can
actually really --
Correlate to what's happening
during that period of adolescent
development and what's happening
in the brain so we think about
what young people are dealing
with and they're experiencing
you know there's this need. To
have peer influence to feel like
they're fitting and they want to
appear more mature they're
figuring out who they are
they're really looking at
sensation seeking activities.
And they get a lot out of this
instant gratification all things
that social media are really
really good at providing on and
what we also see is that success
can come from technology and
social media.
I don't know if any of you ever
watch the MTV movie awards or
anything like that in the past
but like I was watching it this
year I didn't know like half of
those stars.
Because their YouTube
celebrities they're celebrities
from Instagram they're seeing
that they can become successful
and get some satisfaction from
being popular and famous using
social media --
But I don't want to just the
Mason -- So
there's a place.
For community organizing on
social media if we look at
things like the parkland
survivors baking using social
media as a platform to legislate
or ask for legislation when it
comes to gun control.
On and as was mentioned earlier
actually.
A lot of mass violence can be
connected to domestic violence
over 50% of the mass shootings
that have happened have had a
connection to domestic violence
and I think that in some of
these cases.
Including park when there's a
case to be made but teen dating
violence was a contributing
factor to what happened we also
see the need to movement which
was started by Toronto Burke
fifty years ago.
But has really exploded once it
came on to social media and
became that hash tag I'm so we
know we can look at things like
the why I stayed hash tag right
so.
Social media and technology can
be a place to get people to have
these conversations to bring.
Of stories to let to give
survivors of boys to advocate on
behalf of themselves.
So peace over violence we've
done this in different ways
argues created a campaign called
make a choice --
Where they're utilizing social
media and technology to spread
this message of make a choice to
build healthy relationships and
to be an up Stander and say
something and do something when
you see?
On healthy things happening --
Are you posted online Twitter
tax where they create their own
memes and hash tags to create a
dialogue to be able to ask
questions and answer questions
for other people about issues of
teen dating violence.
And we got we can also see how
inter [inaudible]
Lake Road respect dot org --
That's not cool dot com where
teams can go if they have
questions and resources because
unfortunately one thing we also
know is that young people don't
often go to adults in their
lives to ask for help or to get
resources and so these are safe
places.
And some of these places even
offer instead of hot lines like
many of us run chaplain.
Where young people can interact
with somebody and you get
immediate help like?
I'm so I think it's important
that we look at ways to utilize
social media and not just look
at it as something that you are
going to use social media
whether or not we tell them
they're allowed to use it or not.
We as adults use social media
every day and are not going to
just throw it away because
someone tells us that it's bad.
So we need to teach you how to
use social media safely.
And how to communicate
effectively and responsibly on
any to help.
Them identify strategies for
using social media to create
social change like we've seen
happening on any to help build
upon legislation like the
California healthy youth act.
And help mandate prevention
education in the classrooms and
schools and expanded to looking
at best practices for
interventions and response
policies so that it.
Teen dating violence or sexual
violence is happening and is
affecting students we know and
teachers know and administrators
know exactly how they can
respond to those to keep
students safe --
And we can use this because
schools are where students learn
and so this needs to be the
place where they're learning
about how to have healthy
relationships.
How to healthy how to have
healthy communication with folks
include parents in the
conversation so that they know
how to talk to their children
about these issues?
On and just really create an
environment that.
So thank you so.
Talk about young six of this
conversation [inaudible]
Thank you.
The bill comes aye Chau Eggman
with many of you I was former
teacher I taught for sixteen
years and you know it.
At the conversation is great by
reality it's difficult as first
of all of the parents are to be
able to address these issues
with with students if you don't
know -- Or
you don't have access --
To what the the kids are doing
and so the education and of that
the from --
The detective with the education
of not officers but in this case
education of teachers and and
school personnel --
By.
Even the education of parents by
my not question but more of a
general comment is if the
parents are those.
Are victims of domestic violence
the kids are seen as it doesn't
feel practical --
To go to you know to the school
sometimes again if there is no
education by difficult like I
said I was a teacher.
Kids are not --
Very [inaudible]
Trusting --
Because there's a B..
Real possibility that the social
media will be taken away.
And so they're having to balance
the do I come forward.
Right which obviously unless
there's like one you know get
some help.
But they are so I don't see a
ticket their ticket we're all
addicted social media and so a
lot of times they're they're
faced with.
If I say something then the
social media is going to the
ones that are supposed to stop
doing what we're doing in order
to prevent the violence.
And so.
I would like to work with you a
little bit more I'm trying to
figure out --
A balance between.
The case chaired by trying to
remove the stigma or trying to
remove the possibility of the
social media being taken away so
I look for to to working with
all with.
All of you on again future
legislation by if anything --
Conversations I do have brown
tables with my superintendents
levels --
Where it doesn't cost anything
to at least have a conversation
with the superintendent and
maybe come up with --
Some kind of a policy because
the team and we've all been here
the whole morning the theme as
we need more resources on
fortunately.
You know that's not always
possible or I can't addresses
legislators say okay yeah here
you go I've we had a big battle
over an additional just twenty
million dollars --
To help --
You know in cases like this and
it was a huge battle we ask for
fifty and we ended up with
twenty but it took.
Literally the whole entire year
of battling here you.
But there are reality is that
it's not going to be --
As easy and so if what my ask
would be is help me come up with
alternatives --
In lieu of the funding because
funding is always the battle by.
Again I have brown tables with
my superintendent how can we
bring some of these programs are
in the conversations to the
school through.
You know for example me or those
of you that live in other
assembly district to bring them
to the assembly members and I
would love to be a conduit.
Between my colleagues in
Sacramento because everything
cost money and we don't have the
money and so I would like to
also be a resource. To you and
give me information as to what I
can tell my colleagues up and
down the state.
The thing if I could just just
about your comment about the
state of mind used to be.
Will coming for any one of the
is a set up.
Conversation but it just makes
me think about issues of sexual
violence that where alcohol is
involved right and there's this
fear that if I come forward
because I've been drinking.
You know especially if I'm under
age what might happen and so I
think it's kind of a parallel
conversation that we can look at
some strategies in those cases
and apply it perhaps to social
media.
Thank you thank you very much
ilex Natasha.
Hello my name is Natasha Downham
may prevention educator at the
house approved.
On a like a thank you all for
giving me this opportunity to
speak on behalf.
Of my agency for youth that we
serve in our community the house
approved offers understood over
briefly as our twenty four hour
hotline --
Shelter services for emergency
and transitional --
Case management legal services
but the services I really like
to highlight today are the
services that truly benefit are
you which is our prevention team --
As well as our team tech top
line that we have recently
launched --
So just to give a brief
understanding of the prevention
team so we do as we go into the
classroom --
As the same --
Providing with so much education --
Amatil to the we break the cycle
of domestic violence that they
may want to send their own
households.
Providing the different option.
From some other work though
utilized especially with the
technology side is to be able be
advocates --
Through their around which is
social media which they all
typically are involved with.
I'm someone who's been able to
utilize social media within our
own agency is highlighted things
such as him being by was
awareness month --
Highland domestic violence
awareness month and how they can
be advocates on their own
campuses.
And we had to start their own
club single additional service
that we have utilized --
Social media which is
advertising or annual a witness
to our poster contest that we
hope -- What
that our caucus we allow you to
express their themselves their
experiences that they've gone
through --
Whether it be through actual art
canvas art painting and singing
songs lyrical dance we given
that problem given the
opportunity to really utilize
their voice.
And to five again teenage
violence that exists within
their own my I think communities --
We have are you the by three
committee which is a very active --
Member on our board we have you
coming from over maybe ten
school to fifty schools where we
are.
Advertising at the come together
the committee and they learn
about the ins and outs of the
nineteen eighty one is the Civic --
They learn how to be leaders as
well we host a leads training
and to learn advocates do --
In their communities and be
advocates on their own campuses
where it really has sparked into --
Creative club that I just spoke
about on their own campuses and
how they can create policies
within their own schools --
We also have had teams utilize --
You too bye creating PSA --
We provide them with the tools
that we just ask them how can we
help you really want to put the
power in their hands of what
story that in the current --
Like the wanted to be able to
share that experience through
that as well.
And then we also utilize the
technology platform with our
team tax help line that we just
recently started --
Why we began this help one was
the car because he saw there was
a definite need --
For something else I need --
Not being met for resource wise
but are you --
There is a lot of ways we
definitely heard of verbally in
the classroom just discussion
back and forth but I thought
kind of the more.
Physical evidence within our pre
surveys that we provide to our
youth at the beginning of our
course.
I'm with those free surveys are
typically done some kind of meet
them where they're at and
there's a question I asked you
know the resources that are
available to you in your
community.
And over 80% of them stated now.
So -- We
definitely thought it is kind of
a general need their so with
that data.
Only were able to kind of
explore on ways we can help them
I'm eliminate that kind of bare
year.
And as we all know the ins and
as well the does the marketing
they're very connected to their
phone so to me it's more of a
space for them --
So with that we are able to sign
in and increasing data for them
by providing a better service to
them -- With
that tailored service specific --
The a service that might.
I'm just a little history of
that he had his own experience
to work with domestic violence
so he understood the
confidentiality in the safety
risk behind it --
So with that program was able to
create of a and with his
engineering background is able
to create a program that really --
Eliminated Sir bear that would.
Eliminate the state the race
that we could possibly take
place -- So
with that we have Frank
advocates that our own making
our hotline --
Hours of their bill would be
Monday to Friday right now
between eleven AM and five PM --
They've gone through a forty
hour domestic violence training
so they can know the proper
response for individual that is
reaching out for help --
This new innovative strategy and
we need to our youth who are
exposed to are victims of dating
violence bullying or violence in
their own homes.
And it reaches them at the point
of needed their primary source
of communication which is their
cell phones and it also fills a
gap of a service --
Because we understand that is a
scary thing three times the I
need help.
So there may be a lot of fear or
anxiety that may exist in which
prevent them from reaching out
for help especially calling
someone a string on the line --
It's more of a comfort for them
to be able to text someone are
and it's all done through a
desktop system --
Their numbers coming as
anonymous numbers at random to
sign.
I'm at the Armenian reporter so
there are certain situations
where that happens to be broken --
But they have an understanding
and then the phone message.
With our help line --
We have of the city a little bit
about it --
We are seeing on average
approximately --
Forty five taxes for a week and
we slaughter program the second
week of July --
With the understanding that this
is going to be a slow rising --
Program --
Reaching out to our youth and
really encouraging them to
utilize the program into this
thing that we spoke about
earlier.
On receiving help especially
with that so --
It's really been and they
excited we speak about in the
classroom --
Especially with more where's we
bring them on the teen dating
violence so they can recognize
themselves the areas that you do
need assistance --
We definitely foresee this
program be right that service --
If it's not domestic violence
specific we absolutely have --
Strong list of referrals that we
do -- Send
them to the fact that they're
not close --
To our office to work abroad
with our chat services a
counseling or things of that
sort we definitely refer out in --
Are trying to get more
connections throughout our
community --
We service the is the reason of
Los Angeles all the way through
the west in the San Benito
county.
But we definitely have resources
outside of that just to meet
those you that they do come in
our hotline [inaudible]
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Next and last but not least --
We have our own Devon --
Panelists I just want to thank
everyone for being here today
and thank you for having that --
Thank you for the the panelists
for sharing your story painting
really complex complex picture.
Of how domestic violence and
technology intersect.
I'm so my name if dozen mailing
I am YWCA Glendale's prevention
specialist.
In our ninety year history we
have been doing prevention work
for only two years --
Our first focuses mostly on
intervention so what what we DO --
You know what when violence
occurs but we really wanted to
focus on what it wasn't
happening at all.
We take a public health approach
so it's this idea that --
Think about flu season it's
simply that --
What are the little things we
could do every day to stay well
like with the fleet right we
wash our hands we stay away from
people we are sick?
Little things to do to stay well
are a lot easier than the when
our lives are uprooted when we
fall.
This is the approach that we
take to violence prevention --
What can we do to stay well as
an individual and as a community --
And that's for young people and
their use of technology plays a
very vital role.
These everyday acts of wellness
that we promote and are
prevention recognizing warning
signs the violence learning to
manage conflict in a healthy way.
Helping a friend he's
experiencing violent.
Learning boundaries consent.
These are all acts that can only
be learned by teens but these
messages these behaviors these
skills.
Can be spread and promoted by
them.
You have bill extremely vast and
dense social networks all over
the world.
The team I work with tell me
about their best friends in
Texas El Salvador Thailand's
thing.
They tell me how their tweets
have been retweeted by hundreds
of other teens.
How a celebrity might have re
tweeted them --
Team have a powerful voice.
They have a great deal of
influence among their peers in
in their community.
So part of our prevention where.
It's not only exploring issues
of teen dating violence but how
do we harness that leadership
how do we help you find their
voice.
And use it in a way that
promotes healthy communities.
So for our YWCA Glendale our
work started with conversations
and a lot of them --
We went into classrooms we
hosted training for class credit --
We spoke to club immobilized
wallets this on issues that
affect them in their school
sexual harassment dating
violence sexual assault and
racism.
Discuss how to interrupt these
acts of violence.
We talked about how social media
can be a very powerful tool and
spreading his ideas we were
talking about.
And to call out violence when
you see it.
After we had this conversation.
What we notice is students
wanted to talk more students
wanted to get more involved --
I had a group of students walk
from school one day to my office.
To talk about a friend who is
experiencing domestic violence
and what they could do --
I had student to state our long
after presentation was over to
talk about issues of sent that
they were too embarrassed to
talk. To talk about an for their
classmates.
I've had students request --
Other conditions with peers I
had students request
presentations for their parents.
Until it students it's not
teachers it's on adult it's you.
Who want to have this
conversation is you to want to
do something --
Young people are often tool that
they can not enact real social
with little change --
They're told that they're too
young too inexperienced to naive
or two idealistic.
But if you have shown us time
and time again we heard several
examples.
The young people hold Y. ten
jewel in the realm of activism
and social justice work.
And they can realize that
potential through the use of
technology.
I'll give a call.
And that is the question.
She asked me to speak at a walk
out she organized after school.
Protesting the school
administrations response to
complaints of sexual harassment
made against another student.
She had made a YouTube video.
YouTube video went viral.
Spread around --
Schools in New York Texas in
Massachusetts all organized walk
out in solidarity with her --
I had the opportunity to talk to
students that they about consent
ways and we brainstorm ways that
they continue the conversation.
Just Monday I got a call from a
from a teacher at that school.
Who wanted to know how to talk
about consent with their
students --
The reach that hurt it had it
would not have been possible
without technology --
To an adolescent development the
power the peers extremely
important.
Teams are seeking connection
teams are seeking acceptance.
And approval.
And so for me is a great way to
meet those needs.
Social media communication helps
you develop better social skills
[inaudible]
Feel isolated.
Learn about new ideas new
culture.
Bond with their friends.
Express themselves.
And get support.
So why not encourage you to use
that to create healthy
communities.
We know what we see in a
classroom with told to us.
But as assembly member Rubio
mention like we're not that next
to it.
Right we're not in group chat
we're not in hot boys were not
in their social media.
You are connected to their
communities you are connected to
other you.
In a way that we cannot be.
So when young people are then
given the skills and tools
through prevention education to
follow her own voice to create
their own messages.
Dobson we can change communities.
The young people have the power
to make our community well. To
prevent harm from ever happening.
Domestic violence service
providers and advocates.
Policy advocates policy makers.
Continue to focus on the power
of youth in prevention education
we can see things occur
[inaudible]
Thank you.
Will you very much --
At this time I would like to
open it up to a public comment
on if you want to step up to the
podium if you have any comments.
Or if you have questions will be
around and we have the
information of all of our pan.
Mason but if there's anybody
interested in --
Making a comment.
You can come up.
Thank you very much.
I just wanted.
To make a profit and I just
wanted to quickly.
Address just a few things --
Thank you.
I don't think it's about adding
additional resources in fact
when we went through an economic
downturn.
I was invigorated on how we
could change the way we do
business right I think that's
the most important thing --
We have the California office of
emergency services law
enforcement specialized units
grant we have several domestic
brown's grants that are out
there.
It really is about changing how
we use our resources and if we
had priority areas within their
in terms of technology abuse and
there are some in there already.
But we strengthen the language I
think that we can become more
effective across the state in
terms of how we use those monies --
And more with thought and I love
law enforcement specials units
grant specifically because of
Fong course me.
And advocacy they're required to
work together advocate is
required to come into the police
department which I think is.
Phenomenal is been great for us --
We were able to use the
California office of research
grants. To teach our
investigators to do things
differently so no matter if we
lost the money or not.
They were just taught a
different skill sets we
developed an internal program so
it didn't matter if anybody gave
us me because we can do it
ourselves.
So I think that's an opportunity
that also I would just like to
address --
Some of it the stuff that came
up earlier.
Absolutely evicting should not
have to wait thirty days to
going to their house if you have
an emergency protective order
you can go into your house.
And you can obtain some of the
items that you need they're not
going to divide up all of your
property but you can't get
yourself as you can get certain
items etcetera.
The judge can actually lists
certain items of property on
emergency protective order --
On your temporary would not if
you'll excuse me minor temporary
restraining order that's great.
So I do want to let you guys
know that that is out there and
available.
Absolutely if you can't on this
comes out of his agencies in
here but if you can't find a
local advocacy agency please go
to your local family just.
Twenty one the right direction --
And then also I think before
immigration immigration can.
We have got to get better at
training on UV says.
If we can train I mean I heard
people try to use you leases to
absolutely don't need to be used
in the fifties okay.
Under two guys to show up a gun
fight one guy lost okay but we
need for domestic violence
victims we apps or sexual abuse
victims are spousal in a partner
victims understand what that is --
And we're there to help.
Yeah but we really are and we
just need to depart or a little
bit more --
By all means if you got any
issues.
Or need help on how do I talk to
law enforcement.
You know how do I speak the
language.
Please by all means reach out to
me I'll be happy to help you
point in the right direction.
Thank you.
Thank you very much and and you
are correct and I think that's
why are these that hearings have
been so productive in my opinion
because I myself didn't know.
A lot of the resources that were
available and if I you know
consider myself --
Advocate for so many different
things and I have no idea about
these resources I think that's
why it's so important for all of
you to be here today.
So that we can start spreading
the information and I we've
committed to putting all the
resources on our website.
And maybe some of our our
partners and some of my do the
same for will try to get
together with the partnership to
see what what the best way would
be and then our belief.
Might my colleagues to make sure
that all of that information is
on on their cell thank you very
much. One of the S. good morning
of my name's mark that someone
on the field fund road academy
on the theme of the
disconnection.
And I'm very happy. For your
vacation assembly woman like a
total for being here and hearing
all the speakers --
I am soul on excited about all
the information you and agencies
that are available out there in
the community that.
The percentage provided to us
today -- I
do wanna effect --
I ready made a partnership with --
The officer next to the entrance
of Chiu providing training in
Spanish the Spanish community I
work -- My
target that our audiences that
my great community and as many
of you know --
The migrant community as some of
you mentioned of provides allow.
All the violations to happen in
the and it.
Are part of this but there you
use also involved.
So -- My
proposal offer this out to
continue is to not only to
partner ourselves on providing
the this kind of education but
looking for grant.
You know our academy of pretty
much provide the training from
our own personal pocket.
That's how bad a Latino
community agencies out there
providing this kind of a
important information.
They just X. another item in my
academy to continue educating
the community and that worries
me because there's so much
information that you guys have.
The we need to start tried.
A lot of the information we need
to start pencilling a lot of the
speakers in every in every area.
So -- My
proposal to you assembly woman
is maybe to add some kind of a
set advocate. To the migrant
community to continue adding or
looking for those grants or
helping us you know look for
those grants to be sure that.
This will take place and I think
everybody here you guys are
wonderful in my Santa Cruz I'm a
graduate of Santa Cruz we are
definitely going to work
together glasses [inaudible]
Thank you.
Thank you it's an honor to be
here amount until young older
several of us here are CEO devil
if Cristina Locle and myself and
we we are honored because I
think it's quite often minimized.
And it's such an important topic
and and did all you know you.
Have to know what we were gonna
say training is crucial.
We I think most of us as service
providers in the DVD feel we
partner with law enforcement but
we need to really strengthen our
relationship so we listening.
To the conversation for the past
two and a half hours I even a
life sometimes we minimize back
because you know.
Technology up or is a form of
should be protection and not a
product and all.
And that's something that is
very prevalent in the DVD feel.
So I think with training and way
the just --
Reaching out to each other and
also.
Looking out what other service
providers are doing is also that
a trained in the field in terms
of how to reach the the the
teens because for me that was
such a popular thing to know
that yes it is a form of protect.
Of of control but it's also a
way to empower and become a
survivor a TT that may be
experiencing that.
Doesn't have to be harmful it
could be on the country could be
something that could help.
So it is I look forward to these
conversations but to see what
the legislation will also.
Inform [inaudible]
Thank you.
Hello I think these.
Conversations are very important
but I work in a domestic
violence shelter and we just
recently implemented a policy on
helping to get them to maintain
their cell phones and filter --
Many shelters do not allow that.
But it is easy. To service to
our clients to take their phone
so it was a lengthy conversation
and many of our staff are not
trained in technology.
So it is something that we do.
To help us and give us.
Advice and suggestions on how.
To inform them of safe ways to
keep their phones and use them
safely and we did that as a
staff but we would. Eight more
involvement from the technology
companies because taking the
phones from the done does not
help them it hurts found.
And we need to help them to have
all the resources and maintain
their contacts with people who
are supported to them.
And their allies support system.
Thank you thank you and and onto
the comic I I agree I think --
But the lives of the victims are
already up and about the days
and then to take something so
are we live with our phones I
mean it's not a secret anymore.
And to to lose something else --
I think is is a of what's
happening when you take away
that the technology that we
depend on every day and so
that's just another loss of and
basically.
Odd looking at them as a second
class citizens because now they
don't have access to electronic --
So thank you for doing that and
you know I think --
We have much to talk about and
hopefully we can all and try to
figure out --
What we do now after the
conversations and I've said it
many times in our our previous --
Hearing that I love the
conversations by.
We're just having a conversation
and basically wasting our day
and of my commitment and the
commitment from.
From -- Our
partners is that it won't be a
waste of time this is actually a
conversation to begin action
something.
Hello my name is Amanda at the
hidden from.
I guess I had a few questions --
We are looking for immediate
action and thank you all for
everybody information on I
wanted to know at the family
courts like Stanley Mosk armed
the talking parents that's the I
ordered.
Between the parent and the
father and the mother the
children while the border these
battles.
Is there any kind of catch net
to catch domestic violence at
that level because that's
happening now and not as with
current.
And I found somebody who got the
night.
Domestic violence protection
records.
And I represent myself poker
into a woman.
Might have been wasted fifteen
thousand dollars in a group home.
But then.
I'm going to another situation
idea to go here but I need help
because I was.
A child office in god back in
twenty fifteen help me with the
same abuse but never got
resolved.
And now it's affected my
children my children behind --
There was a couple.
Able to the move.
Meyer restraining orders to be
served even though --
To off reports I was denied
represented myself into the
court and it's bad it's it's my
ex husband has the pool. To mess
with me -- I
refer you this unified school
district I had three jobs for
them I'm a one on one for
special ed and I was also
behavioral counselor locked down
so I am a service.
And I work at four different law
firms there is something
seriously going wrong.
And we need to address it like
immediately.
There should be some kind of
caps that at all of these.
Spots where kids could be harmed
and it's just not their the
advocates lawyers.
American Bar such I used to
respect the law.
Now I am just quite surprised
that is not in the chicken pox --
I would like on to talk to many
people I will try to address by
email on my specifically but a
child's office help recruit like
within three days --
I belong to the house of group --
I won at the state level level
and appeals against the county
of for we believe the nine
rights at house of room where I
was that --
Still might be easier was able
to do.
Everything to the point where my
daughters are now ordered to him.
Our views --
So and that's happening right
now.
And that's after one sounding
más.
And my children have been denied
access to three months now which
sets them up a borderline
personality disorder.
So -- I
would like to know my resources
and then we want to get to know
making also great --
But yes I agree that we should.
Have a lot of great ideas at
every level.
Especially with a beautiful
system.
Thank you for and again just to
address --
Some of your your concerns we
have the same concerns --
My unfortunately one of my
constituents is on aye Estevez
on the as the best I had as we
know god lost her child --
Remember that was about the
battle and yet she's my
constituent and I a she and I
have become --
Close friends because we've been
working through this with her
when her child disappeared the
courts gave her ex husband --
Access to the child and after
she said she he's in danger
who's in danger and was denied.
And the father got --
The sun first weekend we are
with you on this battle we have
plenty of our advocates here
then hopefully can help you
today not not via email today.
Because it sounds like this is
something media but I just
wanted to share with you that I
would be working with on now --
And my plan --
For for the feature that makes
coming legislative session is to
work with her because she had a
lot of complaints about the
court system by judges the
advocate all of that.
And so.
We can do everything.
Today.
Fortunately it is a process but
I can guarantee you that we're
working on that because on my
Estevez MPT work constituents
are constituents of mine or
peaky.
May rest in peace is no longer
with us but on aye is helping us --
To write this legislation she's
a huge advocate and is doing
everything possible to make sure
that that families like yours
don't go through the same thing
that her family did so.
By please.
The advocates it here please
talk to somebody today don't
wait for an email because I can
play in the need of the media.
I appreciate that and one last
final comment on McCarty user
was able to only pay a hundred
and sixty three dollars in child
support for twenty nine months
in a row.
And has three DSM diagnosis and
heard.
Immediately please thank you
thank you.
Right just wanted knowledge your
story and thank you for sharing
it with all of us in the room
that --
Credible important for the
voices of ours we heard the
thank you.
For yeah --
Do you for listening.
I wanted to address a couple of
previous comments that came up
the previous commenter talk
about cell phones being taken
away we partner with them it
thinking that project as well so
I wanted to put in a plug --
For those trainings --
We see similar things happening
across the country and
unfortunately it's the same
pattern that.
You know of users use is taking
away devices and controlling so
so wanting to really get into
organizations and assist with
that and I just wanna put it
applied --
For some resources we have it
takes a few dot org --
There's a legal systems tool kit
that's available for law
enforcement and court personnel --
And also an agency you still
care for local programs and then --
Survivor tool kit --
For victims.
Who are looking for a split
around technology safety
[inaudible]
Thank you.
Hi how are you thank you so much
of an honor to be here money
said yes now if I'm with with
the ball park police department
and I'm actually that the method
by the topic at that.
I've been with them for ten
years.
So I know how important this is
for everyone. For as for me I
actually was a victim of
domestic violence from the age
of fourteen always reach like.
Twenty four so I know how
important it is by no one
reasons why you say there are no
other reason.
That --
Sometimes it's hard to actually
communicate that out on I think
it's really important but I
think that I was telling on the
council.
I think that if we could start
something there with the schools
it would be amazing because the
ages that we see that happening
it started hurting I felt.
Really able to a really young
age but it is happening there
another part that I do want to
say is that the long park police
department has done an amazing
job. To keep me that because
when they can't to the victims
the one that talks to them with
myself.
So often apple my with their you
recess on my part to the offices
of Adam at first they were not
sure what it was.
I did a little bit of research --
Was able to do that the last two
thousand and also I think it's
really important every year --
I do want to get some of your
information so I could take back
to one point --
To take somebody's officers of
the park.
Don't really understand so I can
think you and it's an honor to
be.
Thank you for and I want to
welcome --
Councilmember cruise back up
from the city bottom park I
missed you earlier something can.
The room is an armor public
safety commissioner here in the
city of the wording [inaudible]
And I'm seventy years old and I
just now.
Learned about domestic violence
and I don't mean today.
But about three weeks ago I was
on a trial [inaudible]
Which but selecting was.
I guess for the very difficult
but we had a lot of women that
actually got up and spoke.
And that were dismissed.
And it was a key because each of
them had been victims of of a
domestic violence and down.
The first question the judge
asked Japan was.
Did you call the police is a
report on and there were.
The vast majority this it bill.
And they said because they
wouldn't do anything.
And one actually in the in the
more people to get it in a funny
way than the way it was meant
that she had actually said that --
She didn't call and but the
neighbor did because it was a
fight next door and they were
complaining about the noise.
An officer showed up.
And her husband had to be here
and the officers saw her all
bloodied been basically is said
this is a domestic matter and we
really don't handle these things.
So he left and she said she went
to the bathroom clean up and
sure enough when.
When -- She
was nice and clean and the cop
was nice and gone he beat her
again [inaudible]
And it.
Really chair perspective during
the campaña hearings because
when I heard that women speaking.
The victim in particular case
you're handling.
Responded almost directly the
same way.
There was not a lot a consistent
see in the way she responded
there was a lot of confusion.
And pain --
Have a heavy Spanish accent I
request that the interpreter.
Be brought in in.
They decided to ask her about
that at first she said no and
then she said yes and then
finally she said she'd be more
comfortable with the translator.
And the purpose for my asking
that was at the way she was
industry and I kind of was very
convinced that that her attitude
was more from me language
Berrier then from male
[inaudible]
A dramatic.
And it as it turned out her
answers didn't changes she was
cold in Spanish --
Essay questions [inaudible]
And what was difficult for us is
that -- We
were told in the instructions.
That.
There had to be.
Reasonable doubt it if it was
her word against his word.
We have to take his word unless
there was something there
profoundly made that
[inaudible]
And in. Two of the three charges
we were able to find something
different and we're able to find
him guilty.
But in the third which I thought
was probably the most heinous of
the three that was just the two
of them his word against hers so
we had to find him not guilty.
This.
Is route three I think were the
just Justin --
Discourages people from going in.
And the way his attorney can't
describe her.
Was not what we are you know she
basically was in Pierce was
basically.
Still traumatized and she was
basically trying. To answer
questions but she was scared.
But we could use that instant
what we had to use against them
was.
Evidence to support it in one of
the our of come.
He had actually admitted it to
an officer after he refuses
Miranda rights and told the
officer that he in the first.
One it was his attorney speaking
for him that basically convicted
him because she made in exchange
for the first charge but in the
opening and closing statements
she changed her story local.
But the consistency was.
That he had done.
What he was accused of
[inaudible]
So.
I think this is were.
We need to you know as a as a
society --
Find a way of working with these
people.
Getting them you know beyond
their their trauma it don't mean.
Get him out of it and forget it
I mean.
Help them to get to the point to
where they can communicate.
What's going on because this is
for the courts.
Let them down.
And you know and to tell you
that my wife and I we've been
together.
About forty four years and I
when we saw the the hearings she
actually defended Cavanaugh
because she thought this woman
waited way too long. To bring
this out and I had just.
Found out you know first hand
why they didn't bring it out.
So.
I think I got a really different
perspective on the at least
under to know why we were coming
back explaining.
Things if they had gone --
To through.
And this is where we need.
To basically bring along into
line with what's happening.
And I don't think that.
That --
Judges shouldn't go through
trapping also I think they
really do need to because I
think that you know like I said
between my wife and I we have
two different views known is
because I've been on one of
these files and she hasn't
[inaudible]
And it's just the way it
basically perspective and it's
what you see.
Now.
Prior to that.
I was assigned.
Rated based that's what I did
for a living and is science you
basically research everything
you have an order the you put
things in.
And really I think is what
prevented me from even seen
another side of possibility.
But I don't think that's just me
I think that's people in in
general and that's really what
needs to be.
Communicated is finding a way of
of making the nearly
[inaudible]
Communities.
Aware.
Of what to look for what to see.
And one the woman that was
actually interviewing Cavanah.
Accuser.
That I found very valuable.
And that is it.
Somebody tell in a wider fairly
consistent in.
Somebody is telling the truth it
actually varies a little.
Each time because there's some
emotion and some thought it to
what's happening and that was
what I saw exactly in the young
lady that.
Brought the charges [inaudible]
But it's more than just a
complicated issue is something
that we really.
Do need.
To find new ways to address and
new ways. To to work with.
It is not a new problem it's a
very old problems just a new way
of using the and that's where.
You like trying to come in.
And fortunately you know I do
have what they call it mark
phone.
But I'm done with a user.
So.
I get my kids will talk to you
it takes me.
So I had to get a phone that
would let me.
Get text program and when I did
I don't use [inaudible]
But what is the difference is
what's happened in my generation
is happening now is just a
modern way of doing it.
And their generation is gonna
deal with that is a to get older
they're going to find there's no
ways of of communicating so this
is going to be an ongoing thing
but what.
They all have in common is
understanding.
And knowing what to look.
For thank you.
Thank you. For the for the
clothing because I think when we
started the conversation we talk
about how domestic violence
doesn't see color.
Doesn't see gender doesn't see --
Sexual orientation doesn't see
socioeconomic status and the the
response is that yes we can try
and fix the courts by the state
my behind.
That being a victim of domestic
violence until we can --
At least get big to to speak up
we can fix the court system but
if there's nobody going to the
court systems --
Because they're not reporting
their abuse that's where would
that challenge life and I think
we can do both and I want to
thank all the panelists today
all of them are members of the
audience for being here.
Again -- We
would like this.
And action bad like I said
before I'm committed to because
of my personal experience with
my sister but because of the
experiences of so many people
that I've met in the last two
years --
Count on me as a supporter but
also.
I learn something new every time
we have a hearing and I need you
those of you that are experts in
these fields to let us know what
you think fix would be.
Whether the money or like --
The the detective stated not
everything takes money so help
me figure out policies that
might be able to be implemented
without that money so that there
is know excuse --
From -- Not
being able to help them out that
binds thank them so I want to
thank you today for
participating --
We have our advocates here
please exchange cards please
exchange information and I look
forward --
To being --
With you and our next hearing
and so we'll go ahead and a
German at this moment and again
thank you for being here.
Reporting party for we we we
close I would also like to thank
the city of the worry and my
staff -- For
for putting this together we
manage have.
To our items that were doing
today in both on the the city of
the already so we have a purse
here later today but I have
crystal here from my capital
staff.
And I have my district staff I
had laid out for now and Taylor
that are available if you need
any working.
For the city of to argue for
lines to to be here today
thinking